[Music]
let's talk about a particularly
provocative set of experience that
Mareth tubers has done this is
fascinating Canadian research I've spent
so much time with so several years ago
when I first got interested in her work
and I kind of stumbled into her lab I
was working on a different unrelated
project at the time when I stumbled into
her lab I found her showing an array of
pornography so men with women women with
women men alone women alone and even
bonobos having sex two self-identified
straight women gay women straight men
gay men and measuring both their
physical response that is vaginal or
response in terms of erection for men
and then their subjective response via
keypad how turned on do I say I am and
finding something fascinating which was
that where's male response was pretty
predictable the straight men actually
did mostly just get turned on to men
with women or women with women gay men
equally predictable the women were very
unpredictable and kind of anarchic in at
least their physical response so again
there was this big dichotomy the women
were saying I'm turned on by what I
quote should be turned on by straight
women by you know men with women or to a
certain degree I suppose men with men
and and gay women by images of women etc
but their bodies were seeing something
completely different and their bodies
were saying they were turned on by all
of it and perhaps most strikingly you
might think those bonobos having sex but
at least you know reach something
animalistic in men no the men showed
zero response subjectively or physically
but the women did show this physical
response to the
of bonobos having sex so a lot of
interesting things about this probably
too many to name but one for sure is
that the idea of women's sexuality is
somehow more controlled needs to be put
aside if we're gonna do any serious
searching about eros and women and to
this idea that women are somehow less of
visual less immediate in their sexual
other men again need to put that aside
if we're going to do any serious looking
at truths about women's sexuality now
here's a bit of later Cheevers research
that both goes along with but also pulls
us in a slightly different direction
than that original set of studies so
remember part of the original set of
studies shows women being quite anarchic
in what they're drawn to Cheevers
decides ok let me take a set of straight
women self-declared straight women and
show them just four types of photographs
and see what happens four types of
pornographic photographs so we've got a
flaccid and these are kind of
disembodied genital shots just so we
have nothing to distract us not a pretty
face not a handsome face etcetera so
we've got a dangling flaccid penis we've
got an erect penis we've got a kind of
coy soft porn female crotch shot legs
together and then we've got a leg spread
more hardcore shot so the straight women
do respond to all of it physically but
that erect penis
sins the platysma graph the measure of
physical response soaring and it's just
an indication again of rawness immediacy
and just a kind of this is about sex
let's be careful before we complicate it
with all the factors that we habitually
complicate female sexuality with there
is a core to this and we shouldn't be so
quick to look away from it
[Music]